-Performing "Animalz"
from their upcoming new album
"The Big Sleepover," give it up
for Big Boi and Sleepy Brown!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Let's go ♪
-♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
-♪ The birds and the bees,
how can I relate? ♪
♪ I never learned that story
about sexuality ♪
♪ I knew that man and woman
come together, procreate ♪
♪ To make a baby
and to take your legacy ♪
♪ Off of the line
you take the sex away ♪
♪ Now do you really
love your babe ♪
♪ The way you think you say ♪
-♪ You do? ♪
♪ Well,
that's a beautiful thing ♪
♪ But you can get that
brand-new kit-kat ♪
-♪ Never breaking up ♪
-♪ Keep the bars intact ♪
♪ It's like a massager track ♪
♪ It's like that act before that
Gucci, just massage it back ♪
♪ And she was starting back,
back to that booty up ♪
♪ If you move it up the side,
and that booty sorta pops ♪
♪ Wazzup? ♪
-♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're delectable ♪
♪ Treat you like an edible ♪
♪ Oh, so sexual ♪
♪ I just want a taste ♪
♪ One drop, I won't waste ♪
♪ Please don't hesitate ♪
♪ You can ugh,
all over the place ♪
♪ Now what you gon' do? ♪
-♪ Check it out ♪
♪ Shakin' and shimmy for two ♪
♪ Gotta beer,
drinkin' water for you ♪
♪ Gotta ask
but you burden with truth ♪
-♪ You know why ♪
-♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
-♪ It's like a what?
It's like a what? ♪
♪ What? ♪
-♪ Like a zoo full of animals ♪
-♪ I know that's right ♪
♪ Big Sleepover ♪
-♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
-♪ Take that,
take that bonnet off ♪
♪ We'll get your hair done
later on, on ♪
♪♪
♪ I said, take that,
take that bonnet off ♪
♪ We'll get your hairpiece
later on, on ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ You might get ready
and pay the due ♪
♪ Yeah, but the boss
ain't never do, do ♪
-Ain't that good?
-How y'all doin' out there?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
♪ You're incredible ♪
♪ We're just sexual ♪
♪ We're just animals ♪
♪ It's like a zoo
full of animals ♪
-Fly to roll.
Big Sleepover.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!